hey youtubers is Charlie this gonna be
my legend of korra episode 8 video
another was a little bit confusion it
was a clip show Branko on yet go to Li
explained it sought to a breakdown of
what he said
even though there was an attorney
footage I did enjoy the way that they
presented the old stuff
the even tease some things that we've
been asking for for a long time
to see could chose don't have to be all
bad but careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet
starting with top five moments number
five prank on yet go
explains the clip show so essentially
what he said is
is that Nickelodeon slash their budget
they found out at the last minute
in they would have either had a fire
everyone on their staff a week
early or use a clip show break treat
their crew like families they were never
gonna fire everyone a week early
for everyone is asking why it was
necessary for them to do an episode
when they could just skip episode 8 gone
straight to episode nine
Nickelodeon order to specific amount
episodes
so they didn't deliver this episode
Nickelodeon could have sued them
for example they needed to delivered 13
episodes
for book Fort to complete nickelodeon's
contract with them
so a Nickelodeon slash their budget
before book for started production
it still had delivered 13 episodes but
the crew that hired in though
workflow that they had like the way they
developed episodes was based
on but book threes budget was so there
really wasn't a way around this
didn't include firing people or using a
clip show
they couldn't just skip the episode are
not included
clip shows can be kinda dumb they tried
as hard as they could to make it not
suck
they did reference that Nickelodeon
kinda pulled the rug out from under and
the higher ups
they also reminded us in May shows do
this all the time
example that they specifically reference
was samurai Champloo
as a show that deep clip shows in a
really good way so they tried to model
this episode based on that
I feel like this is the point where
everyone's gonna cue up some samurai
Champloo desi with the reference
material look like
it's a great series you should check it
out if you much the head and since Ralph
and the Last Airbender we can pick up
this is like an ember island players
episode
I know lottery already commented that
you felt like ember island was a little
bit more enjoyable than this episode
I will say yes that episode was a little
bit
more fun just because the tone was
lighter just because the tone a book for
in general
in what happened the last couple
episodes everyone was a bit of a Debbie
Downer in this episode
even though they tried including hopeful
moments those crazies it is that we had
to get a clip show that this close to
the final episode
a village in the core ever is a reality
of the business it's like a very
Hollywood type thing
your budget get slashed and they have to
deal with it number four
Marco explains mccaw rub who else forgot
how relationship ebook one was
I was even making YouTube videos and
that was a ring that how long ago that
was
the whole point at the Marco whooping
was that tagline that he had at the end
I realized I better focus on being a
better King based on book four so far it
seems like
that's what they're saying we were up as
he will be keying
it'll be a more balanced virgin what the
earth Queen was
but he won't be as big of an idiot this
is we were talking about
so he'll never stop being a complete
idiot is just like the journey that
earth king went on during avatar last
airbender we also get to see Marcus
character development
he's not done yet somebody asked David
Faustino
if we would see mock ok right before the
end of the series
and he just responded with this tweet
that said hahahaha
does a lot of evil cackling I don't
expect there to be any relationship
Easter
in the finale I mean they'll have some
resolution to get some closure
bring out my coasters and grated
expressing himself so I think by the
last episode he'll get there
I mean it's going to be the last episode
alleging a core ever so why would you
cry your eyes out
number three corners on me not to be
confused with course I mean
I see tend to use those terms
interchangeably other course I mean
something completely different
this was a bit of a Debbie Downer seen
core is mostly looking back
at the things that she's done it
thinking what %ah said none of that
matters
there's never the right time out a
balance nationally Asami an intense
they're there to slap in the face just a
little bit
before is all about balance so it's
implied by the end but there will be the
right amount a balance
I don't think they would in the series
without that resolution
although I do think that they'll endings
in a way that will let you know that the
Avatar cycle will continue on
in order for that to happen don't have
to be a new conflict so the may be
teased for a new conflict coming along
but they can just continue in the comics
as much as we've had this big could be
read WTF thing going on in this one
I feel like the end is going to be a
compromise she's not gonna kill could be
your interests
wash everyone in giant energy form
number two
many commentary about overthinking the
logic really are my favorite moment
happened during that last
sequence with Boldin and Derrick very
client was probably one of the most
important ones in the episode
don't let truth get in the way of a good
story don't overthink things
if you like that's break talking to the
fandom you know just roll with it
don't overthink the logic that brings up
conversations about
you know how powerful skoro without her
past lives conversations like that
arguments that you get into with other
fans summon the logic that they set up
in legend Korra
like the past lives robber avatar won
has contradicted the logic
up Last Airbender that happens a lot of
times especially with shows the go on
for a long long long time
The Simpsons is a really great example
that in its also another series The does
clip shows
all the time I can only imagine how bad
the quality would dip
if the Avatar series went on for twenty
years my number one absolute favorite
moment from this episode though
was the alleged decor a movie the
greatest mover ever made
that's as close as we're gonna get to
legend core movie and it's actually
pretty awesome movie
who knew it would turn out to be such a
comedy when my big hopes for Bowlin was
that after the event a book for over he
would go on to become a movie star like
Ian berry
which is going to make movers eric is a
scientist in a businessman so help right
do all kinda stuff
boleyn you know who knows maybe also to
lobby bending Academy
ta started a metal bending Academy
hopefully there'll be some movers in
there somewhere
it was so funny that they got all the
original actors to come back and do that
don't seem with the phone conversation
I love that collectively as batons they
all hate you unlock
but is looking to he sucks you like the
butters their group
to see general though for what they had
to work with I felt like it was a great
episode
look good show it kinda sucks this close
to the finale but I feel like they still
did a really really good job with that
let me know though what was your
favorite moment and if we actually did
get a legend a core movie
do you want to look something like this:
you know would you be happy with a
comedy like this
so just a quick reminder next week is
pieds gonna be episode 9
and then the week after that is a theory
they're gonna post all four
the final episode at the same time
do it like that two-hour finale
situation obviously it's all streaming
online
if you are watching on TV or he hadn't
been watching online
they're gonna start airing it on
Nicktoons on November 28
and autumn you're wondering about avatar
videos after book for Stein
I will continue to videos for the new
comics and out still do bonus videos for
Last Airbender legend Korra I never did
make videos for Last Airbender
or even book one so I may go back in do
that at some point
there's all kinds of fun stuff we can do
I will be doing attack on Titan videos
whenever season 2 comes around
if there are any other really big am a
series that you think I should do videos
for
just leave me recommendations in the
comments and totally open to anything as
long as there's consensus
you know I want to do something but
everyone is gonna enjoy replica that
if you guys haven't seen me talk about
it my other videos you watching on your
mobile phone
on a tablet you to give me new been a
feature to play with just links appear
it's the same as the link that post ever
hear which'll still be the same but now
you can click here for last week's
legend a core
and you can click here for the Q&A the
top post tomorrow thank you so much
watching thought of high five
I will see you guys tonight